doo doo dah dah well why the fancy music
to kick off the harlot highway ah well
why not got a great guest on the show
with me today she'll be here the whole
show will be interviewing her funny
charming intelligent sexy witty all
those things and more and we're gonna
have a whole bunch of fun I won't tell
you her name but wonderful guess I'll
tell you once we get on to the other
side of this intro of course I will but
I'm trying to bait you a little bit i'm
trying to build the suspense we're gonna
have a blast we're going to be talking
about you know terrorism we're gonna be
talking about rabies city talking about
first dates romance we're gonna get
obnoxious we're gonna get fun we're
gonna play place of games just an all
around a good time here today so i hope
you enjoy my my special wonderful guest
she'll be here the whole show is you
know i don't often have guests but today
we do i'm very lucky so here we go it's
special guests i'm here on the Harlan
highway the Harlan highway please you
are you listening to Harland Williams
over Johnny it's over nothing is over
just don't turn it off you just made a
wrong turn onto the Heartland highway
welcome to the Harlan highway oh you can
your money all right everybody here we
are on the Harlan highway what a delight
what an extra delightful treat today
it's like dairy queen used to say scrump
delicious and the reason it is today
because I've a very wonderful guest here
today and you just heard her make an
appt little baby owl noise and it is a
she um and she's a wonderful actress she
has her own podcast she's an improv
superstar she does so much and I'm lucky
to have her here Vanessa Ragland is here
how are you good how are you what a
treat how's it going oh it's going great
it's just going so great oh you look
great you always look great Oh says the
horse to the other horse oh I'm a horse
now in a good way oh thanks Tony you
look lovely too ah thank you well I
still model yeah not ever model robyn
overtly constantly did you really oh
yeah for real now honestly ever i could
why not too ugly and don't so not
interested no you could model easily i
think i think can people look you up
online or would that make you [ __ ]
uncomfortable Oh
it made me so relaxed I yeah look me up
and then rate hot or not and just email
me at info at pop my culture podcast
back up what we'll see what wait what's
hot or not it was an old dude it was old
website yeah maybe the 90s and it was
the predated Facebook and all these
things but it was just like women or men
would upload their picture and all the
only purpose was people arriving hot or
not no thinking hot or not that's for
real yeah and you were on it no oh I was
never on it but I'm saying we could do
that to me i can upload a picture i can
be a rating system that will ruin i I'm
just gonna I'm gonna like forego that
and just tell everyone vanessa is hot
ladies and do yeah save your damn time
um so we're gonna be talking with
Vanessa tonight we're gonna be we're
gonna be asking or probing questions
just give us probing answers we're just
gonna chew the fat like I'm not talking
regular fatty if you ever chewed the fat
off like a buffalo hide no that's that's
the kind of fat we're gonna to tonight
yeah and um and then later in the show
we're gonna play a the harland highway
famous game that I do with all my guests
and I don't often have guessed but the
nest is just such a treat I wanted to
have her on the show we're gonna play
too soon or not too soon it's gonna be
fun I'm already very nervous and then
we'll close the show out with its it's
an option question it's the called the
obnoxious question and you can don't
decide now but i'll ask you at the end
of the show if you want to answer it or
not do i have to decide that before you
answer yeah oh yeah so think about see
how the interview goes pieces are
falling see how you feel and then we'll
go from there and then we can close with
a prayer I do you want to close with a
prayer like that yeah absolutely think
this is your time yes if you want to
close with a prayer ah but close with a
prayer hey uh I just wish sharon stone
and closed her legs oh god not really no
I don't think why would anyone know
everyone's very thankful for that thanks
Sharon yeah thank you this one is doing
it for the sisters Oh first question
have you ever had rabies I have not
you've never been attacked by a fox or a
like I'm gonna talk by a fox but I've
never wait a minute you show you when
was this 1962 you were attacked by a fox
yeah what happened I mean I was it was
my own fault yeah being at the hunt I
shouldn't have been at the honey you
were a fox hunt right where in England
England in 1962 it was a crazy time you
were four years everyone crazy wow how
old were you I wasn't even born exactly
you're attacked by a fox in the womb
yeah wow that's why you didn't get
rabies you were protected by placenta oh
you're probably right yeah we've been
trying to crack that for a while oh my
god have you ever been attacked by an
animal like it outside of the way yeah
chicken a chicken rooster yeah I mean
only Birds why I've grew up on a farm
and but not exactly like a a layman's
farmaya neighbor was a veterinarian so
she always liked harbored all these sort
of busted animals yeah I love animals so
I was over there all the time yeah
taking care of whatever it doesn't sound
like they loved you back though not the
chickens are the Roosters why case they
sleep in trees which I was a quite aware
of i thought they had a coop situation
there was a coop but uh hold on chickens
and roosters sleeping trees hence the
roosting there roostin they like to know
that and i frighten them on a walk home
late night after I've been feeding some
squirrels with an eyedropper because she
rescued these on the flying squirrels
and I was taking care of him cuz they
were gone and I was walking by the trees
and then rock they flocked you you got
flour Oh was the forest would you say
it's one of the worst flocking you've
ever had you know nothing like that
there's been many worse yuvan locked way
worse yeah well but how many times have
you been flocked out on a country road
late at night with an eyedropper in your
hands the handful really and this was
though this was the worst we're not the
word ways no they were ways that was
only flocking from on the record it was
one flocking you were flocked by what's
a male rooster called is it a rooster
isn't it something else so a [ __ ]
you were flocked right I was cocked
locked the middle of the night with an
eyedropper in your hand just after
you've been giving this heart of gold
tarnished slightly did you have to do
like therapy and stuff after you got
blocked by the [ __ ] in the middle of the
night hey probably I didn't isn't that
that could be a kids book flocked by a
[ __ ] in the middle of the night yeah
that's a good book I would be a good
kids books and then lastima beacons
don't walk in the dark don't walk in the
doc when the [ __ ] might flock Yeah right
you're like a modern-day dr. Suez you
know what he was a great doctor is it
sue us for soos soos soos it's gonna be
soo ass that's something to take up with
a dead man honey but it doesn't it seem
like it's sooo acid is how i would say
it and you did yeah i've just to be fair
to him I've never heard anyone makes a
mistake do you think he was a real
doctor chair you'd honestly like the guy
that wrote green eggs and ham sam-i-am
you've got how does it just a killer
cancer ham Slam by ham like how do you
how does dr. Seuss diagnose your
ailments he has bad news that you don't
even feel it sting you because it feels
so happy there's such a bouncing rhythm
it's not till you're in the car and
you're like oh no diet I saw a box on a
fox ovarian cancer you have lots what so
much have a great day my doctor he's a
fun guy wait a minute I think I have of
your head Wow yeah why did he get dr
maurice sendak who wrote where the wild
things are he didn't he's not dr.
maurice sendak he's just Murray said
that he is sergeant Morrison oh yes so
he's in the military the make-believe
military just like they make believe
medical school what about who was it the
Rope Winnie the Pooh as somebody milled
wasn't it h mm-hmm age something else
melon right maybe H is like hospice
maybe he was a hospice nurse
yeah and wrote about a dog named poo or
a bit a beer named poo yeah and not a
great choice for no kids book very tacky
actually really tacky whoo hoo bear
wonder if I wonder if he wrestled with
11 de stool the bear one day she said
hmm it's not day My Fair turn one day
loaf the bear that's kind of a cute name
yeah loaf is cute weenie the love way
neither loaf Bonnie little stuffy little
stuffed with fluff he's witty though oh
and does it eat honey in this world no
did something else butter or something
he's the father of bread I guess you
could put honey on it are we getting too
dirty let's move on rabies it so you
don't I've never ever ever of rabies ok
ok aah are you I've never been had
rabies I mean I got a little defensive
no jumpy and notice I said had which
doesn't mean I don't have it now does it
seem like I'm rabid a little you're the
frothing isn't good probably I wonder if
I hurry aggressive look at my shoe would
you say I have a lucky rabid foot I got
do you have to go you have to got
figured after that you'd have to leave
wow this was good thank you for dropping
by I was just in neighborhoods oh please
don't get flocked on the way home God um
let me throw this out yeah ok Vanessa
you're the last person on earth ok
everything for whatever reason it's gone
haywire right it's like the bombs went
off a virus whatever you're wandering
around alone yep one other person shows
up what would you rather have this
person be a mathematician an architect
and engineer an artist or a
Jeff this is a great question yeah and
you're gonna be you know your [ __ ]
presumably you're gonna wander around
this will be you know this will be your
better half now that you found them
finally yeah sad sad dystopian mess yeah
I guess I mean is it the tacky choice to
say chef it might be the tacky choice
chef interesting why why'd you go there
because of food being good yeah you know
and I guess yeah I guess a chef whipping
up like a burnt dog leg on the side of
the road which or something that a nice
zombie souffles I would have never
thought of on my own some carrion
pudding oh yeah she's just intestines
that are already running right um how
interesting choice chef I think it's a
basic choice i feel bad i should have
chosen something else know that since
it's probably primal because food when
you're when you're in a situation like
that that's so desolate and barren and
foods probably the most primal response
and i'm thinking my other options okay
for the last people on earth yeah
there's not really much hope I mean yeah
maybe we could procreate but even then
that's gonna die out fast because it'll
all be incest so you don't really need
to like try to save anything you just
need to make it through the day and
that's true and a chef's personality is
probably very passionate and very like
he does it for the love of it whereas me
a mathematician or an architect was
pushed into it by their parents and
they're unhappy and not with them no
thanks see that's a great answer because
I you the way you put it makes total
sense I probably would have drifted
towards engineer so they can figure out
just so like they may figure out
shelters and things it but but then you
put it right when you said look there
there's really nothing to nothing around
anymore better just try to have fun yeah
and I want to eat well if it's possible
in this can you imagine just sitting out
in a burnt-out building with a delicious
like pheasant under glass or yeah
suddenly it's absurd and interesting
instead of just sad it's like can you
believe I'm having the best meal of my
life after the apocalypse oh just like
truffled potatoes and
delicious Danish casserole while sitting
on a pile of dead bodies or something
that's so nice and you can I mean
there's that show have you watched that
last man on earth no um oh the with the
Will Forte yeah yeah yeah is it good
it's very good well yeah I will say as a
whole is very good you know it's got its
ups and downs yeah yeah but um it does
feel a little fun to imagine being able
to go into any house you want or do
anything that would be cool yeah just
like okay I mean you would also be so
very sad and empty yeah yeah but any
anything to get through what would you
do if you went into people's houses do
you think just clean you can clean their
houses after the apocalypse yeah I think
it would be aren't you can ride Oh like
plaid better yeah and for brie would you
Febreze I think the stench will be in
too deep but I would do the surfaces I
would do the floors yeah like polish and
wax yeah all of it pledge for sure that
delicious pine scent Oh lemon pledge
lemon pledge oh yeah there's like a dead
rotting corpse in the corner and your
you pledge the coffee table everything's
gonna be just oh oh yeah I could have
all the nicest appliances in the world
Wow dysons everywhere sucking up dog fur
from long gone dead dogs yeah are you
okay I'm not sad I'm happy because your
answer surprised me it's not the one I
would have gone for but I loved that's
why I asked it because I thought
whatever the answer is they'll be some
interesting reasoning behind it I liked
where you went with that thank you very
much caught me off guard oh um now going
back to today's world where we're all
alive and we're functioning and we're
happy and we're having fun what's the
best date you've ever been on and this
can go back to high school let's go back
to when you're a teenager do you
remember it isn't it something that I
don't have something that springs to
mind immediately you don't have one like
I'll talk a little so maybe you can
check your memory banks but I'm thinking
was there a date that took place in a
romantic setting or an exotic place with
a
super special person even if it didn't
work out with them right maybe you were
there and had a moment yeah I feel like
for me I don't have a great memory in
general I sort of like block things out
very quickly but I've had so many lovely
relationships and it's like but probably
the memory that we the best one would be
closer to the first because those things
always make a bigger impression right
when you're when it's new right and
you're you've never experienced love the
feelings are so yeah I was thinking
about that recently like to be a
teenager is so crazy yeah because you're
just so full of like people can feel
like yeah cracks you open in the
craziest most intense way so of course
all teenagers are insane they're like
just it's not just hormones everyone's
hormones know it's there are moans they
haven't experienced the bad things are
yeah ality yet so it's just like that
adrenaline high ah does god that's
amazing in there I'm thinking I think
there was something in high school Chris
Campbell if you're listening yeah great
guy Chris Campbell sweta specialist
cottage kid yeah raping Scotland um he
was such a sweet sweet boyfriend but I
think the most fun thing was I went away
one summer to like governor school and
heard of that governor's school yet week
that I I don't know if it's just I was
in Virginia for this I don't know if
it's a Virginia thing but it's like sort
of often arts or sciences but like
little magnet programs kind of and so I
went for this playwriting one that's
what it was for I was just like I spent
the summer in the city and it was so fun
no but he like drove to the city and we
went out to a restaurant it felt like
the most adult thing yeah yeah how old
were you 17 oh that's a good kid a good
age oh and I was excited to like cuz at
the end of the night I get went back to
my dorm room not my house and my friends
were there i guess it was like almost
having a college experience in high
school and yeah very exciting wow so
that was good I remember like getting
excited about getting dressed like oh
we're going to a restaurant the
grown-ups go to but I didn't say that
cuz I was 17 was it a fancy restaurant
no but not the olive garden so it wasn't
the olive garden but it was it was like
a guy
for where you're at in life it was it
was nice it was because in our town we
lived in a really little town like the
good restaurant was the olive garden oh
wow was like a good restaurants oh this
was like we went to a nice little cool
restaurant it was so fun but not the
Olive Garden hottie so that means if the
olive garden is the best you went to
place one notch below all of no I went
to a place above all I'm hardness Oh a
bomb yeah for sure oh my my uh maybe
wrath of language order on the olivine
nice yeah but no free breadsticks at
this [ __ ] awesome Wow on that note but I
mean you know you talking about those
first experiences and this one was
always awkward for me but do you
remember the first time you French
kissed oh the dude yes adorable did you
get it or was it like was there drool
and tongues all over the place they'll
wear self in the world I feel
comfortable saying it was the Morrison
yeah i think it was for every kid almost
i think mine was worse what happened
when you refers races oh boy brother
banzon whoa i didn't know it was coming
when it was kind the tongue the guy's
tongue yeah yeah the whole experience
yeah we were just newly dating yeah I we
were in the barn I just scooped some
sweet feed for my horse and then I like
turn around its like oh no no no what's
happening and I'm like my tongue is like
trying to undo the UM rubber bands you
know like I'm panicking trying to like
that I know oh well the rubber bands
holding your mouth shut like on the
sides on the side right like I just felt
such intense Wow and the smell of sweet
feet is burned my head so you're also
not good I'm not gonna name his name
yeah was it was it all over the place
like slobber like a jackhammer just a
minute they're like so aggressive oh I
mean but he wasn't an aggressive person
it was just he didn't know we didn't
know we were doing too bad you didn't
know how to manipulate your elastics and
you can alike shot them with his tongue
right oh and you would have been with
Malik I would hold out thought that it
was sparks that would bark it's like oh
wow wow I don't know if I'd met a lot of
people who can say their first french
kiss was in a bar
yeah I pretty good whether their
livestock during the french kiss my
horse was waiting for his food so there
was a horse but he wasn't in the store
when I was getting the food so there was
no animals in the barn during the make
out no witnesses okay okay my face I
remember was not like I used to blush
horribly like really confident in plays
and things like that I had to do things
like that surely shy in class yeah and
look this was like my skin was on fire
oh my parents are gonna know they're
gonna know cuz I can't come down from it
you know would have been the best if in
the middle of that aggressive french
kiss you got flocked like that giant
[ __ ] go down the [ __ ] flew down and just
attack both your faces and then its
claws got caught in your gun in here
your prices oh that's the worst thought
a chicken with its foot stuck in your
braces yeah yeah very claustrophobic and
afraid yeah yeah very scared frightening
alone yeah all those things that's my TV
show I'm pitching it is yeah and naked
very naked frightened scared and alone
and smelly umm e string so did this did
this this french kiss guy did it ever
evolved into a relationship we were
already boyfriend girl for all really it
was very like uh huh you want to go out
with me like that kind of thing yeah
yeah going out high school stuff yeah
but it didn't last long after that kit
did it kind of turned you off you're
like oh this guy's not very passionate I
didn't know what to expect so I was more
just like hey don't think this is for me
like it did even as a teen it didn't get
you fired up oh no oh god is like dad on
fusing to me like cuz he was really cute
I mean I hate it farm boy yeah the short
end of the stick for sure in terms of
the looks department he was so cute but
was he did he have overalls on yeah
they're put away the bear girl he kept
this John is not the whole that's what
it was oh yeah I remember the first time
I wanted I didn't know
how do neither of us knew how to manage
the air in your mouth and so we were
always saying well this was when I was
like 17 or whatever and and you know is
probably this girl's first time make it
out my first time and we didn't really
know how to manage you know the air in
our mouths so when we'd make the seal
the air would be in our cheeks like you
know chipmunk store nothing and so we
pressed together it would like seep out
and be like we'd be making fart noises
with Irma as we're making out it was
horrible yes I was like this for you in
a barn no we were on a beach near be all
around a campfire oh that's really good
though it was it was very good it was
hot but I could tell we were both morons
at kissing but it was still steamy and
hot at least at least we had the passion
okay um here's a quickie and this is
just a real quick answer like okay you
know probably five words or less then
we'll move on to some of the bigger ones
ah here's the quickie for Vanessa
Ragland right here do walruses use their
tusks to open canned goods or do they
use a can opener real quickie here they
use their tusks the user talk a good but
that's correct ah here's a heinous this
questions gonna get your blood pressure
up oh no yeah um you're on a plane ah ok
everyone can relate to this terrorist
stands up and says he's taken over the
plane in all likelihood it's not going
to end well what do you do I stop him
with my cool moves you do like the very
gonna french-kiss on ya get the elastics
from your gums I'm I wouldn't I could do
some kicks me what do you do really
you're sitting there but take this is
real so scared in a horrible yeah it's
very horrible what do you do they make
you ask I know it's wild right but
remember you're kind of your kind of the
voice of a lot of people listening right
now because people are probably going
what would I do I mean what do you do
you just are so sad well do you resign
yourself to the fate of this guy or do
you formulate a plan do you they make
some kind of exit strategy do do you get
aggressive well maybe that could be good
if I'm in an exit row I could pull that
thing maybe I don't know how that thing
works exactly you just pull it but would
that do something I don't know if this
is your plan you tell me oh you know
what I'm guess what I am on the plane
what the Air Marshal so I have a gun no
no you can't you're you you just decide
as him you're just a beautiful citizen
Vanessa a glam sitting there you're not
even in the exit row then at their head
maybe but you would okay like but I
don't know what and it will just get me
shot very quickly but I feel like I
would do some scary thing and then try
to hide under my seat until everyone
dies really and if there's any little
people try to get them under seats but I
know if he's gonna take us down we're
all dying or are you unless there's an
intervention if I can that's why I'm
asking do you think you can prevent it
do you think there's something you can
do or do you just sit there and wait for
the inevitable I mean maybe you can make
allies with people and then you can
group together and just mob the person
like that right if you start so would
you be the one to organize that would
you be the instigator maybe I mean now I
feel like I would if I had been on a
plane yesterday and this happened I
would know I would've been a chicken
[ __ ] but now over time you would have
just SAT there yeah I'm like well why
would you why would you just sit there
there's only a chance that there's only
a slight chance that's something that
will not happen right you do something
if you don't do anything you're a
hundred percent right yeah so I should
do something so that's why I'm asking
you to get into that mindset and see if
the you know this is like it's almost
like if you're lost in the forest what
are your survival instinct how do they
kick in put your on a plane like a
seizure I don't think well there you go
that's always what I think I would do if
someone was attacking me yeah street
like I would just like dick just try to
terrify them with your having it yeah
that's a good idea I think that would
freak someone out like an attacker I
think that would freak something out
because they don't want to be around a
person that might die
yeah yeah they don't want to be blamed
for it and also that wouldn't be very
fun to have your way with like a
convulsing spitting person yeah so maybe
I would use that tactic on here too
because it could distract the person
long enough that maybe somebody powerful
could do a Power Move it's interesting
you say that because that's what I
thought you know if it happened to me
first my first instinct would just to be
like hell now I've had enough of this
stuff I would just like fly over the
seats and you know rugby tackle the guy
oh but that could get me shot in midair
so then I thought what if I'm being like
strategic and it's funny that you said
the seizure thing because and with no
offense to the mentally challenged but I
thought what if I kind of cuz you know
we do acting what if I was in a
convincing with convincing way able to
kind of act like I was maybe mentally
challenged and kind of oblivious to the
terror and kind of at some point just
stood up and pretended I need to go the
bathroom on the guy like kind of
reprimand me I'd just be like i like i
would Burt I don't know what you know
what I mean and then at the when he
least expects but use my not acting
ability I think that is the way to do it
I'm goody-goodies I think it is a good
plan like you may not have strength but
you can be distracting in an unusual way
you gotta screaming person not blind
person that's what they expect them for
that that's we're not ready for the kind
of crazy you might be able to serve up
exactly that's a good plan I like yours
because you are a big person so yeah and
it would just be like kind of sad at
first and then boom whoa exciting cuz I
think that you know people are it's like
your seizure people are thrown off yeah
my stuff they're not used to her
comfortable well so a terrorist first
inclination of he saw a mentally
challenged guy like kind of stumbling up
the alley might not go I must kill this
guy he might even have a shred of
compassion of his heart and be okay let
the guy go to the bathroom he's not
going to hurt any one of the wam just
break as FML right yeah I think this is
a good plan if we're on the same plane
it can be in
incahoots yeah I can see he's looking
over there you get up you have to pee
yourself so that it looks like it's real
or spill some water on your crotch yeah
to paint a picture seize your girl and
mental gai save weighing the world save
the world yeah that's another great dr.
Seuss book surat yes you know there's a
suez canal i am part of it but have
never traveled in is it named after dr.
Suez for sure what else i did we named
after i don't know what's wrong I'm
asking um let's go to all let's go to
our um our game okay you ready this is a
game we play with all our guests on the
Harlan highway it's called it's a simple
game it's it's four questions too soon
or not too soon as the only two answers
so you should do really well at it I'll
ask you the questions and you have to
kind of do it you have to answer like
too soon or not too soon you ready
Vanessa Ragland here we go question
number one for too soon or not too soon
Olive Garden's all you can eat bread
sticks is getting old and they now have
a new campaign all you can gargle old
people skin flaked bathwater too soon or
not to sin oh no I was wrong yeah did
you really write that question yeah
about the olive garden yeah unbeknownst
that we don't be talkin right here
number one let me let me wrinkle the
papers to them right there oh yeah right
there on that piece of paper but
unfortunately didn't get the answer
right you ready for number two don't got
three to go to sundar not too soon
question number two Smokey the Bear is
looking pretty good these days since he
represents forest fires should someone
cover him in barbecue starter fluid and
Exxon ultra supreme gasoline and throw a
burning
garrett him too soon but not too soon
soon correct correct nice nice beautiful
question good you got one you're tied
third question number three with more
and more conjoined twins being born
should walmart start selling three foot
wide bicycle helmet to sit or not to sir
not too soon oh I don't you tell me I
mean how is that too soon I feel like
that's great timing and Walmart should
it really is monsters safe too soon okay
you're back to the dog all right last
crawl you can do is tie all you can do
is tie unless I have a seizure oh oh
she's having a siege do I win I better
call dr. sue us all right here we go
last question too soon or not too soon
with all the political correctness in
the world these days should a dog have
to be present in the room and be forced
to watch and even possibly join in when
people do it doggie style too soon or
not too soon yes doggie style is a
sexual act no I no no is it too soon or
not I cannot help you with that was that
it clear that was got a clue too soon
not too soon sorry Rach it's too soon
yeah yeah sorry oh you got one right oh
well great for me yeah you got the
Smokey the Bear one throwing the burning
ouch I just thought wrong yeah man
I know I'm sorry okay you tried I really
did gave it a good try got my whole self
to the whole thing you committed you
really you thought them out you didn't
rush well you gave me a fake clue I did
yeah he said not in your answer Oh God
give me a clue not oh man no that was
not the clue all right well we are down
towards the end of our wonderful
interview but we're gonna end it this
could be tough now this is called the
last obnoxious question and you can
decide to answer it or not answer it and
it's going to be obnoxious it's kind of
as if two guys were sitting around the
campfire talking about jet you know just
like guy talk and I think girls do this
to a degree too so don't be offended you
can you can you can decide not to do it
or do it well I'm so interested all
right I'm going to decide to participate
who you are yeah okay here it is but I'm
still in charge here and I can say no if
I don't want yeah you can you can end by
the way even if you say is your answer
can be so small that it's almost like a
no okay but we're gonna ask it and
remember it's obnoxious and I hate to
even do it to a beautiful lady but it's
part of pushing the parameters of the
Harlan highway I put your night ass and
what else are you gonna do not assuming
here it is have you ever thrown or stuck
a used tampon own anyone or anything
oh yeah just a couple of guys sitting
around think am I I know it's horrible I
feel horrible but it's the type you know
when you were kidding well yeah why
because if it was guys who had their
period you know they'd be like bro I
just threw my tampon at an owl dude it's
stuck right to attend if green is I can
answer this yes honestly honestly I have
not done that okay I'm almost relieved I
am completely I'm really I appreciate
that you were willing to go there but
I'm almost relieved because you're such
a wonderful elegantly but I know if he
did have one it would probably have been
wild and funny but but it would be so it
would be horrible horrible be obnoxious
I could never recover my image do you're
not my brand I don't even I don't even
want to visualize it my brand will be
wrecked but all I oh it will be behind
my lotion no one would buy fumes you'd
be done in this town Oh God but people
listening will be riveted people would
be sitting you know how little kids used
to sit by the radios back in the 30s and
listen to Dick Tracy and with her little
decoder rings yeah people would be going
oh my god what did she throw her use
tampon at have used on a used tampon no
but I haven't had my first period yeah
okay well when you do what I do I
probably well yeah I'll probably swirl
it around and throw it at like a crow
errs on birds oh wow yeah why am i
throwing him at Birds why my matter burn
maybe a waiter maybe a waiter the
Cheesecake Factory hey slow ass oh I
know to see if not worse isn't it nice
that manessa raglan didn't even have an
answer for that that's that's it's good
but I had to do it woman you are classy
beautiful wonderful lady did you have
fun here on the Harlan my wife I did all
right now before you go I want people to
be able to you know find out where you
are what you're doing I know you have
your own amazing podcast please please
tell the folks how they can get you on
social media how they can get your
podcast all this
things I have a podcast called pop my
culture podcast with Col Stratton and
you can find that on the internet at
www.mypocketcandy.com life com we're
just kicking that one off Wow and Jamie
and I and no limber are gonna start to
do a weekly show at the hollywood improv
so if you're in town you should come by
on friday nights i'll have more details
about that i'm sure on my twitter which
is at Vanessa Ragland and the show at
the improv will be like a stand-up
comedy shore like a variety show variety
show oh oh oh yeah we'd love to have you
on Harlan hmm and you say good stuff we
do it off really some level it's the
most fun and the happiest so that's
really exciting I guess those are the
most of the things and then I do a show
in Santa Monica that you guessed it all
about that called pretty pretty pony and
it's every like oh I'm so bad at this
it's on Mondays every once in a while
check it out yeah bad you could also
find out about that on my Twitter I'm
sure I'll tray when I'm gonna do that
yeah yeah yeah and so many other things
and my personal phone number oh yeah I
give them back 310 yeah 6480 certain
yeah I think I got it or not oh I'll
give it to them all right sounds like
you had a little hiccup no no that's my
that's a little seizure but I'm yeah
coasting through okay i'll give it i'll
make it clear to them later well you
know after you leave all that a little
make your phone number very very easy to
act like a one-click situation yeah ah
well there she is folks unbelievable
classy right to the end even rolled
right through the last obnoxious grit
which I hated to ask but you gotta I
mean you work for the guy and he's an
[ __ ] you gotta do what he says I have
to it yeah my boss mr. Featherstone up
on the 12th floor ass munch but I don't
love this building by the way you don't
it's soulless yeah its soulless probably
because of him he's an ass munch um
folks look her up listen to her podcast
and Vanessa thank you so much for viz
hang the Harlan highway thank you so
much for having me on the highway no I'm
going lower oh we have to end with a
prayer oh yeah oh my god do you want to
lead the prayer I we can go either way
okay why don't you said you want to do
it why don't you everyone close close
Rocca close my eyes take a nice deep
breath I think the dragon god and how
his fire engulfs us all may we all hold
up everything that needs to be scorched
may be scorched but leave our hands as
soft as satin amen unbelievable I love
it thanks for letting me talk about my
religion so spiritual right at the end I
know it's a little a little weird but
hey I am Who I am oh I was that was
empowering I hope so Thank You Vanessa
mm-hmm oh there she is Vanessa Ragland
ladies and gentlemen I hope you enjoyed
my my little chat my fireside chat with
Vanessa what I would a treat what oh out
now treat ah so that's the show let's
move on to let's move on to some
announcements here starting tonight oh
yes tonight ladies and gurgle blackens I
will be in portland oregon or portland
oregano however however spicy you want
it right next to nutmeg the state of
nutmeg i will be at the helium comedy
club october eight this is tonight
thursday through the 11th which is
sunday helium comedy club in portland
oregon get your tickets at Harlan
Williams calm and then two weeks later
October 23 and 24 friday and saturday
only I will be in denver colorado at the
Comedy Works what a treat what a tasty
treat
so I look forward to seeing you guys
there as I said tickets available at
harland williams calm just click on my
stand-up comedy link while you're there
uh you know check out the harlan highway
merch store all kinds of fun gifts there
for you what else can I tell you you can
leave me a message there if you want or
you can you can write me uh well I guess
that's the same as leaving a message but
you can you can write me a message or
you can leave me a voice message there's
a contact link on the page but there's
also a phone number 32 37 39 for 3 30
and feel free to the phone and leave me
a message for god sakes if you want ah
so there you go october eight through
the 11th portland oregon and helium in
october 23 and 24 denver colorado at the
comedy works um and that's it don't
forget to get the new app the harland
highway app on android and apple just go
to your app store on your phone and type
in the harland highway and there's an
app player it's real easy to use it's
really convenient you'll never miss
another episode of the Harlan highway
there's also a way for you to shine up
sign up for premium membership where
you'll get all the backlogged episodes
I'll also get premium content special
stuff I'm going to be recording and all
kinds of stuff i'll tell you more as
that comes out so thanks for being here
give my thanks to Vanessa Ragland hope
you enjoyed it guys and until next time
chicken chow mein baby a [ __ ] I was
caught [ __ ]